lucien badjoko bonsoir bonsoir et
bienvenue parmi nous merci alors vous
êtes étudiant à l'université de droit de
kinshasa congo ex zaïre
mais à 12 ans vous avez été enrôlés dans
les milices de laurent désiré kabila le
tombeur du maréchal mobutu et vous êtes
devenu ce qu'on appelle un kadogo
c'est-à-dire un enfant soldat
pour vous la mitraillette c'était pas du
tout un jouet c'était une arme qu'ils
pouvaient tuer si cette enfance
africaine que vous raconter dans un
livre coécrit avec katia clarens publié
chez plon qui s'appelle j'étais enfant
soldat
alors tout commence en 1996
vous allez avoir 12 ans le teint enfant
plutôt heureux ici d'une famille aisée
il faisait quoi vos parents lucien mon
père était un homme d'affaires
alors un jeu d'octobre vers midi vous
sortez de l'école et là vous décidé de
ne pas attendre le chauffeur qui vient
vous chercher régulièrement et de marché
et sur le chemin vous croisez un ami qui
s'appelle pascal pascal lui et militaire
dans l'armée de mobutu mais il est
contre mobutu il est partisan de kabila
et ils vous convainc de rejoindre avec
lui les rebelles de kabila et vous le
suivez oui sans discuter ressent
discuter parce que j'ai
je voudrais bien jouent aussi manier les
armes mais j'avais s'est senti mal à les
manier les armes bonjour et de libérer
mon pays la dictature de toutous qui a
été lavé le 30 30 ans et il faisait il
se faisait aussi qu'il y avait là n 1
qui était en moi
ensuite certains histoire au pillage des
militaires de mobutu il on vient me
fouetter en jour emilie terrain donc il
y avait là cheminement de choses plus
fait que je puisse être décidée
je pousse mes décider vite pour aller
libérer mon pays la dictature alors
lucien vous partez avec pascal
j'imaginais pas une seconde que votre
existence va basculer vous est excité
vous êtes joyeux vous voyez des gens
schwarzenneger en chuck norris sont jean
claude van damme quoi vous avez envie de
jouer avec les armes
oui en fait quand on est enfant je
savais pas que la vie d'une personne été
sacré mais je ne savais pas aussi le
sens de l'amour donc je prenais la
guerre comme un jeu d'enfant comme un
jeu vidéo wii le camp ont joué parce que
c'était l'ambiance qui étaient ses parts
après que j'ai pu comprendre que la
guerre la vie d'une personne est sacrée
et que
on peut pas mettre même sa vie en danger
comme ça pour une politique sans
scrupules
voilà alors vous partez vous partez
directement sans prévenir votre famille
jusqu'à un centre de formation au rwanda
hélas à peine arrivée vous êtes
dépouillé de vos affaires on vous vole
votre veste que votre mère vous avez
rapporté d'un voyage et vous êtes battus
immédiatement avec des branches oui il a
fait comme il le disait il fallait haute
et l'esprit civile ils nous oublient pas
possible c'est horrible difficile à
expliquer et en égalité des enfants on
n'en veut pas à faire c'était la loi du
plus fort est toujours la meilleure on
sait la faire aimer
on est obligé de supporter c'est là
alors on vous demande de dormir par
terre il ya même pas de palme vous
dormez à même à même la terre même le
sol un seul a pas de maison de détente
petites tentes
et puis beaucoup de sport des ponts pour
vous fait courir enfin on vous dit tu
dois apprendre à avoir le coeur dur dire
qu'on essaie de vous endurcir au maximum
vous un enfant de 12 ans il faisait tout
pour que nous soyons violent nous
puissions pas comprendre il faut faire
de vous des bêtes sauvages
oui voilà alors certains meurent de
coups de botte dans la tête dans le
ventre enfin surtout ceux qui veulent
s'enfuir du centre de formation parce
que on ne s'enfuit pas du sang entre une
fois que vous êtes là vous êtes obligés
d'y rester en quelque sorte vous donner
prisonnier des gens chez qui vous vous
êtes engagé si vous essayez de fuir et
qu'on vous attrape on vous tue ouais on
vous tue on vous tabasse pas possible
avec des branches de
il ya aussi d'endoctrinement c'est à
dire qu'on vous bourle on vous bourrer
le crâne
on vous dit du mal de mobutu alors ce
qui fait qu'à un moment déjà vous le
détestez au départ mais à force de vous
en doctrine et vous finissez par avoir
qu'une seule envie dans la tête comme ça
c'est vous dites liquider ses chiens de
mots boutiste liquider ses hyènes au
boutiste c'est à dire vous êtes
complètement fanatisés oui souvent le
soir vers 18h 19h quand de la morale
connaissais un peu de nous expliquer de
nous faire voir comment mon bouton et et
dictateurs comment il a traité nos
parents comment il nous a traités
comment il a mis le pays dans le gouffre
et tous comment mon goût tu es plus
mauvais et cette idéologie là qui nous
changer l'esprit de plus en plus ça
c'est ça nous incitait de le faire
partir vite qu'on avait toujours envie
de le faire partir huit avants pas
termine même l'un la formation mais oui
oui vous voulez toujours à les combattre
à partir de là vous vous interdisez de
penser à votre famille parce que vous
dites c'est terrible comme un poison qui
s'instille en vous dont vous vous
refusez même de penser à votre passé à
votre famille à votre mère à votre père
en fait ma mère
j'ai nommé beaucoup j'aimais beaucoup et
ma soeur jeanine c'est arrivé que
j'aimais tant mais se faisait que cacher
fois que je pensais à eux je pleurais je
pleurais tous les jours tous les jours
je souffrais fort je n'arrivais plus à
me tenir
je n'arrivais plus à surmonter cela mais
après un temps j'ai trouvé que c'était
comme un poison parce que suite à cela
je n'arrivais pas faire autre chose
était toujours dit ce trait à certains
moments je me suis dit comme je trouve
comme si ça un poison qui qui pourrait
peut-être mettre fin peut-être un peu à
ma vie un jour il fallait que je mette
ferait cela un jour que je pensais à
cela je suis conscientiser je me suis
décidé de ne plus penser à cela voilà
alors bientôt vous êtes nommé
instructeur et là à l'âge de 12 ans vous
découvrez l'alcool les cigarettes
ça participe aussi de l'endoctrinement
cette idée que le tabac commence à vous
plaire vous dites au bout d'un moment
mon meilleur ami c'est le tabac vous
commencez à voir davis quoi oui on
donnait un de l'état bat un peu de tabac
et de tombacco à l'état brut qu'on
distribuait et dans la nourriture c'est
par là que nous avons compris que l'on
mette un peu du chanvre mais on nous
interdisait de prendre dix ans au centre
de formation mais il ya un ami qui
m'avait dit un jour qui était cuisinier
cas ce qui m'avait dit un jour non voilà
vous savez pourquoi vous avez
découragent souvent c'est parce qu'on
mettait à fait un peu du chanvre de la
louis tillaye main et j'ai vu tout
compris effectivement il y avait vingt
treize ambiance qui était en normal à
certains moments après avoir mangé plus
en plus d'essayer de regret donc alors
finalement vous êtes pas désigné pour
aller au front vous restez au centre de
formation lucien là vous devenez
commandant et ce qui est terrible c'est
que vous découvrez l'exercice du pouvoir
vous commencez à tabasser les jeunes
recrues à votre tour c'est-à-dire vous
faites aux autres ce qu'on vous a fait
quand vous êtes arrivé en fait c'était
une sorte de revanche d'un fr voir les
goûter au pouvoir vous avez parce que
comme sommes arrivés on a vu comment les
autres ses enfants et
des hommes comme nous et qui nous
traiter comme des animaux enfin nous
sommes dit voilà on m'a fait souffrir
dans ce que je dois faire souffrir tout
le reste qui vient et on voudrait mais
la mettre un exercice et petit pouvoir
là qu'on avait sur les autres mais comme
ça qu'on a pu faire souffrir les autres
ils sont venus quand vous tabasser les
autres ou tabasser les jeunes recrues
oui et vous profitez des filles aussi
c'est comme ça que vous perdez votre
virginité c'est à dire qu'en fait il
suffit de dire à une fille ce soir tu
viens chez moi à préparer et la fille
étaient obligés de venir
oui on avait ce pouvoir là on était les
réducteurs il avait rien à nous dire
vous aviez l'air a fait comme l'armée
les hommes ne se discute pas ça fait
vite quitte là ils n'avaient pas de
choix
je vous dis pas sur moi vous devez
passer chez moi c'est pas se fâcher
moins de punitions qui nous attendent et
voilà ensuite vous allez au front vous
êtes capitaine de 16 personnes à l'âge
de 13 ans et là vous êtes envoûté par la
musique de votre arme si vous avez
l'impression de son jeu vidéo là vous
pouvez tirer vous pouvez tuer des gens
vous vous rendez pas compte de ce que
vous faites
en fait au début la savane est pas
content c'est ma cote ont été incités
par l'ambiance vous savez il y avait des
chansons qu'on chantait de la révolution
de la guerre il y avait l'ambiance des
chansons qui nous faisait voir que nous
sommes en train de libérer notre pays
qui de la dictature des chansons qui
nous fait de voir que même si nous
perdons notre vie c'est celle de la vie
pour notre nation pour notre pays
même s'il ya 3-4 qui meurent les deux
qui restent vont construire le pays et
ont été vite
incité par ses sentiments là et quand on
tue et on ne voyait pas continuer de
gens je veux que c'est l'ambiance parce
qu'on chantait quand tu enchanté on ne
voyait pas qu'ils se la vie des gens
qu'on est peut-être de perdre c'est ça
quand vous croisez un accord vous dit
tonton et terminer mon frère et puis un
jour vous tuer pour la première fois
alors évidemment au début ça vous fait
un choc terrible
puis je me sentais étrange j'avais
l'impression que mes cheveux voulait
sortir de ma tête
et puis tu es devient de plus en plus
facile parce que les enfants n'ont
aucune conscience de la main et quand on
a 12 ans on se rend pas bien compte de
ce qu'on fait lucien session oui la
première fois les tués on savait c'était
horrible c'était terrible d'expliquer
cela parce que
vous savez quand vous êtes en fin d
année mais j'ai été obligé de tirer
parce que il ya certains principes de la
guerre quand vous voyez notre le premier
il faut le tuer parce qu'un vite un tube
et je m'en vais sentir vraiment emporter
par certains sentiments
il y avait le char des poulpes mes
sorties sur le corps et offrira maison
maintenant de le faire et de voir
comment les autres tombent les sautes d
amis qui quittent humeur qui sont
déchirés pas de bactéries vous raconter
des scènes de carnage est absolument
apolitique un au fur à mesure qu à l
habitude de tuer c'est battre sans
scrupules sans regret il ya des scènes
terribles avec un un militaire qui fait
tourner un enfant non en tenant par une
jambe et l'enfant va s'écraser contre un
mur en face et tu ne sais d'une
sauvagerie absolument terrible alors
quand vous arrivez à kinshasa vous êtes
accueillis en libérateurs évidemment
tout le monde vous voit arriver avec
kabila
mais en fait les gens se rendent pas
compte que ses enfants sont devenus des
bourreaux et au bout de quelques jours
les kinois les habitants de kinshasa
commence à avoir peur des enfants parce
que les enfants sont devenus des
monstres vous à moindre blague quand
vous tuez vous - dragons nous y sommes
moins d'avoir envoûté la population
commence à avoir ma et du monde il y
fait 10eme sont des enfants sont des
enfants sont des enfants et par après on
en fait on évite haï par la population
alors vous vous avez torture et vous
même vous avez torturé vous raconter il
ya un jour vous souviendrai toujours de
ça c'est quand vous enfoncez la
baïonnette dans le dans le genou d'un
mec et vous sentez une résistance et
vous voyez le regard du type et ça vous
pouvez pas l'oublier ça oui ya un type
fêté hier est belle comme on peut bien
l'anémique on avait capturé un jour
comme d'habitude ça c'est fait et on
veut être capturés par la mer
1 et si tu ne te tue pas tu ne suscite
pas et si votre cape to cape tirez vous
serrez vraiment mal traités et ce jour
là c'était horrible c'était ma première
fois de participer aux tortures durette
et c'était horrible de les faire et
souvent deux fois ci je pense à cela ça
fait du mal au coeur et ça ne fait en
fait ça ne m'est pas à l'aise ça ne met
pas en paix l'armée n'est pas la place
tous les enfants ouais
l'armée n'a pas la place pour les
enfants c'est bien des démobilisés parce
que vous savez aujourd'hui la majorité
de la jeunesse africaine se sont lancés
dans des fêtes au service de manier les
armes et comprennent et je me suis dit
aujourd'hui que demain après demain
qu'est serré l'afrique où l'humanité
dans le sens que la majorité de jeunes
qui sont l'avenir de demain sans
lendemain s'élance de ce genre
d'histoire et qui ne sont pas instruits
mais mais après demain on aura quel
genre de médecins
quel genre de dirigeant au quel genre de
militaires qui parce que nous étions de
guerrier nous n'étions pas de militaires
parce que pour être un militaire à
l'officier général général il faut
passer par les académies militaires et
comment ils seront assis mains certains
responsabilité du pays de l'afrique du
continent d'afrique ou du monde avec
cette instruction qui n'a pas atteint
l'objectif de le principe général
alors vous vous en êtes sortis vous
faites des études à l'université de
droit de kinshasa mais vous croisez
encore dans les rues des anciens enfants
soldats qui sont jacky air quoi il vous
dit il ce livre du kérosène ils savent
pas quoi faire ils se sont perdus
oui je les croise toujours parce que
nous avons l'association nous avons fait
l'association avec des amis qui qui aide
les amis qui est de les amener à
comprendre cela à se maintenir malgré la
souffrance à retenir à prendre la pose
et la bonne position dans le sens que
nous sommes des enfants ne pouvons pas
continuer à travailler pour l'armée nous
sommes entrés d'être exploités et que
nous devons préparer notre avenir pour
que la démobilisation réussissent à
audrey restaurer la paix parce que tant
qu'il n'y aura pas la paix est encore à
la guérir les enfants soldats
on ne mobilise aujourd'hui demain et
après demain mon jeune frère aussi vont
suivre vont chercher à défendre leur
chacun sait peut-être ce sera à défendre
sa famille son ami ou lui-même pour se
sentir en sécurité et il doit se faire
enrôler pour contre les armes pour mieux
se sentir en sécurité poids quand lucien
aujourd'hui vous avez trouvé votre
réconfort dans quoi dans la religion
oui dans la religion aussi la religion a
beaucoup aidés chic catholique et
les vidéos fait je dirais quand j'ai
passé au centre des sortes d'idées de
transit
les psychologues ces longs mois n'ont
pas pu effacer tout ce qui était en moi
mais avec le concours de l'église dans
l'encadré des nôtres encadreurs à
l'église est à la chorale parce que je
me suis installé en chorale magnificat
avec son encadrement parce que l'anc a
des ailes à fut mon professeur au
secondaire ils savaient bien que j'étais
militaire
il m'a vraiment encadré avec son apport
l'apport des dieux a appris hier et je
pu retrouver ma p
on ne sait pas quoi dire mais on n'a pas
des mots pour qualifier ces personnes
qui ont obligé des enfants etc oblige
toujours aujourd'hui à des enfants aller
à la guerre il n'y a pas des mots et
d'hébreu et au la deuxième chose que je
pense qui a créé les armes qui a vendu
les armes pour qu'ils s'entretuent les
frères africains et on a mal au coeur de
voir ses déchirures dans un seul pays
comme les comores congo 1 et j'ai dit
que il y a un temps qu'il faut pas il
faut pas perdre le temps que quand vous
arrivez trop tard eh bien il ya beaucoup
des dégâts que ça très difficile de deux
degrés d faire ressusciter ces personnes
là mais ce jeune il a il a eu le courage
de lutter contre lui-même et tout ce
qu'ils avaient cuit mais c'est l'horreur
et pourtant
eh bien il dit il a trouvé la paix mais
grâce à dieu et on le souhaite et on
l'appuiera toujours et et on souhaite
que tous les autres enfants qui sont
encore dans la guerre puis sous le seul
exemple oui parce qu'à pâques aux dégâts
causés en côte d'ivoire il ya beaucoup
de l'enfant soldat
moi ce qui m'a frappé c'est quand il dit
est ce que ça me rappelle quand il dit
j'ai été instructeur on m'a battue ou
torturée et puis quand je suis devenu
instructeur j'ai fait ce qu'on m'a fait
un jour je vais quand j'étais en algérie
dans les années soixante deux sans trois
j'avais rencontré un algérien qui
avaient été faits prisonniers qui
avaient été torturés et et d'autres avec
lui été torturé il me racontait qu'un
des types qui étaient torturés ont le
ramener à la prison pantelant terrible
des plaies par tous et c est ce qui le
réconfortait c'est de raconter les
tortures qu'ils feraient subir plus tard
quand le pays sera libre à ceux qui
l'avaient torturé ta main toujours
frapper ça comme quoi il faut faire tant
d'efforts pour imany c'est notre notre
terre
l'hymne anisé parce que on se croyait à
l'année 2000 quand on passait à
une époque qu'on va être tous des frères
et bien malheureusement nous en nous
entrons dans un autre ère où n'existe
pas cette fraternité où on s'éloigner
les uns des autres
1 et quand ces enfants soldats
mais ça il faut lutter avec toutes nos
forces pour que ça cesse et tous les
gouvernements ce qui aide les pays qui
ont des enfants soldats des vrais à caen
ils z imposé que airways perd 10 et 2
n'est jamais aider un pays qui a des
enfants sont depuis ça c'est l'afrique
mais ne disons pas c'est l'afrique c'est
l'afrique ça s'est passé en yougoslavie
c'est à dire en europe c'est à dire à
quelques centaines de kilomètres de nous
il ya eu des enfants soldats
la majorité des amis au feutre quand
nous sommes venus pour la libération du
zaïre la majorité des enfants de
libérateur soi-disant à trier mètres
étaient des enfants des 12 13 14 20 de
moins de 18 ans
aujourd'hui que sont les enfants qui
sont des combattants du siècle or nous
devons pas faire cela
les adultes ne veut pas ses terrasses la
devons chercher à humaniser la terre ne
vont chercher à préparer l'avenir de ses
enfants et la jeunesse de demain parce
que vous savez dès mai après demain
cette génération repasser etc nous le
jeune qui vont prendre rélève et qu'est
ce que nous allons faire si nous n'avons
pas conscientiser le vieux pour nous
préparer aujourd'hui parce que vous vous
avez déjà réussi votre génération et
nous méne ans le jeune donc nous devons
nous unir nous le jeune entre nous les
conscientiser le jeune et nos frères
jeunes aussi les conscientiser pour
préparer l'avenir
l'humanité de demain l'afrique de demain
où le monde et demain florent
non mais c'est vrai que là tu rentres
dans des témoignages ou un moment donné
nous ont habitué des émissions de
variétés dites de divertissement et là
ce n'était pas hyper divertissant son
histoire dont il ya un moment tu fais
whaou qu'est ce que je suis en train
d'entendre et c'est ce que je ressens
comme vibrations donc après me demander
ce que je peux dire là dessus qu'est ce
que tu me dises si j'ai quelque chose à
dire là dessus c'est qu'il ya un moment
j'ai pas compris
merci lucia les corrections de ne rien
rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus